πως γεννήθηκε αυτήη ιδέα ισκέψη να πάμε να διεκδικήσουμε το ευρο πάς και τ κόσ
ηδε εναι είναι ιδέα του κόρνο ιού δημήπωσηφθεο καιρός να να φτιάξουμε υποδομές που αρμόζους
σε μια ευρωπαϊκή χώρα που θέλει να αλαβανειτέτοιου ίδους διοργανώσεις θεωρώ ότι με τη επιτυχή
αντηδική μας έχει ανοιξ δι αυτός όλι διάλογος και έχουν βγεί στην επιφάνεια προβλήματα το
οποία κρίβοντα τα τελευταία χρόνια κάτω από το χαλί πήγίνεται με το ζεο θα πορέσει
αφφανέλα της εχνηκής κύπρου φοράιτάχι κε μια ηθεράτη αλήμηση προς την κυβέρνηση μελόκληρη θέλούμε να
υγάλουμε όλου ας προπροωπους και πρως στον αθστον πασκετσιών κόσμο γιατί περιμένουν όχι να δούν
τις δκάπτεμέρες τς διοργανωσης περιμένουν πια θα είναι συμπερηφορά μας την αμέσως επόμενη μέρα είναι
θνική υποθέση τπάι και το κης ςμέντα δεείναι δουλεια του ενώς είναι οδυλεια τις όμως
πονίες μας κατμόνείνα θνική υπόθεσηιλές και φίλει άλλο έννται ένα λλά ευποτικά σήμερα μαζί σας
εδώ στο πλατό μαζί μου ο πρόεδος σκαυπιακίσουμος τον διας καλάθόσφερας και ος να δρειάσμου
ζουρίτης αφούσεμερικούς μήνες θα έχουμε μια από τις μεγαλύτερες διοργανώσεις που έγιναν στη χώρα μας
γύρω από των αθλητισμό το γυρον πας καιτ αλλά θα συζητήσουμε γενικά τα της καλαθώσφερας
για το πιο συν πρόεδρος αλλά και άλλα θέματα γρο από αυτό και μος βρωίδη
χαριστώ πολύ που ίθα στε σήμερα εδ εγώ ευχαριστώ για τη πρόσκληση και λπίζω να
εξαντέλησουμε τα θέματα το οποία έχις υκοψεςενικόενικό ήταν α το κόναρχικά ξεκινούμε θα φέρναται σήμερ
το τρόπειο τελικά εκτατός στην αθήνα ήρθαται όμως μεταλο τις αλλονικές άλλον κύρθες όμως μετα
δώρα σο ευτυχώς τα οποία θα πούμε έψι να συνέχεια στον κόσμο πω αρχικά νωρίσω
όπως πάνε οι πρωτημασίες θα το προλάβουμε τελικα τεγειο ιδογήπεδο και νακάνουμε τη διοργανώση εφυσ